as you probably heard the West is
suffering through one of the worst
droughts on record which you might not
know is that costs of the consequences
of that drought could touch the pockets
of everyone across the country NOAA is
predicting the drought in the West will
persist or intensify through the end of
July worsening drought conditions mean
vegetation is drier and burns more
easily the parched western US seems to
be set up for a record wildfire season
in California things are already
scorching there have been over a
thousand fires this year that's almost
double the five-year average because of
that the National Interagency Fire
Center is estimating the threat of fire
will be higher than normal in June
across California Arizona and the
Northwest and then in July and August is
the temperatures increase the area in
danger of wildfires expands even more
all this is bad news for taxpayers since
2005 the federal government has spent
more than a billion dollars a year
fighting fires in the United States
number was closer to 2 billion in 2006
and 2012 and with drought conditions
like these 2015 shaping up to be another
billion dollar a year
you